اعلنت دائره الشرطه في مدينه سومي شمال
شرق اوكرانيا عن مقتل شخصين واصابه 20 في
قص صاروخي استهدف مؤسسه تعليميه في
المدينه يذكر ان مقاطعه سومي شهيده انسحاب
القوات الروسيه منها في نيسان ابريل العام
الماضي
للمتابعه معنا الان من دوناتس كمراسل
الجزيره نور الدين
لمتابعه التطورات الميدانيه واخر
المستجدات فيما يتعلق بها نبدا بالجانب
الاوكراني مع القمر الحاج
نعم ازدهار القوات الاوكرانيه تتحدث عن
استهداف روسيا لمدن وسطي وجنوبي حتى اقصى
الشرق الاوكراني مدينه سومي بشكل خاص
القوات الاوكرانيه ايضا تحدثت عن مقتل
الشخصين في مدينه في مقاطعه نتيجه استهداف
روسي بالطب طائرات مسيره اضافه الى قتلى
سقطوا في في مدينه سوم عاصمه المقاطعه
ولكن على الجانب الاخر هناك اعتراف ضمني
اوكراني بالمسؤوليه عن استهداف وسط مدينه
موسو قلبي مدينه موسكو هذا وفقا لما يمكن
استخلاصه من حديث
القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه الذي قال ان من
اعتاد على الهدوء والسلام عليه ان لا
يستمر على هذه العاده في اشاره الهجوم
الذي تعرضت له موسكو فجره اليوم بالمناسبه
هذا هو الهجوم الثاني في اقل من اسبوع
العاصمه موسكو وذلك ايضا كان قد تبعه نوع
من الاعتراف الضمني على لساني مستشار مكتب
الرئاسه الاوكراني ميغايلو الذي قال ان يد
العداله وانها ستنال من يلحق الاذى
بالاوكرانيين المواطنين وايضا بالمنشئات
الاوكرانيه وهذا وفقا لو وصفه ايضا القوات
الاوكرانيه مستمره في قصف شبه جزيره القرم
في مناطق مختلفه من هذه من شبه الجزيره
تلك خلال اسبوع بشكل يومي تستهدف السكك
القطار وايضا تستهدف جسورا وخطوط امداد
اضافه الى استهدافها لقواعد عسكريه ومخازن
للذخيره امس كان هناك قصف الجسر الذي يربط
البر الرئيسيه الاوكراني بشبه جزيره
القرموه في امس الاول كان هناك استهداف
لمستودع الذخيره اعترفت به القوات
الاوكرانيه على لسان ايضا
البيان على بيان جاء من اداره استخبارات
عن استهداف لهذه
المواقع من جهه اخرى القوات الاوكرانيه
تحذر من نوع من حمله جديده او استهداف
جديد لمواقع في جنوب البلاد تحديدا
المنشات البنيه التحتيه وايضا موانئ
اوديسا وموانئ ميكولايب بعد تسعه ايام
متواصله خلال الايام الماضيه هذا التحذير
جاء على لساني نتالي المتحدث باسم قياده
عمليات الجنوب التي قالت ان القوات
الروسيه ربما تستعد لحمله استهداف جديده
بعد ان
وصلت الى نقاط محدده او استهدفت النقاط
المحدده وانها ربما تغير من خططها
وتكتيكاتها مشيره ايضا الى ان القوات
الاوكرانيه اخذت كافه الاحتياطات طبعا كل
هذا يجري ازدهار لابد من الاشاره الى ان
هذا يجري في ضمن حديث عن احتمال لوجود
لقاء او جوله مفاوضات جديده قد تستضيفها
المملكه العربيه السعوديه هذا وفقا لبيان
الليم او مقال للوشمبوس اريد فقط ان يشير
الى ان نتحدثنا الى مسؤول اوكراني قال ان
اوكرانيا تنظر ربما او تدرس احتماليه
الاشتراك في مثل هذه المفاوضات على انها
ستناقش خطه السلام التي تقدم بها
جالا تشير الى السحاب روسيين من كل
الاراضي الاوكرانيه والعوده الى اتفاق الى
حدود عام واحد وتسعين